speaker this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
gary sanbrook thank you mr speaker over
the last week thousands of people
across frankly great park and south
norfield have done what's been asked to
them to go and get a test because of a
small number of south african variant
cases
in the constituency would the prime
minister join me in thanking dr justin
barney and
cancer simon morale and birmingham city
council for everything they've done to
be able to scale up mass testing
across frankly great park and encourage
anyone who hasn't had a test so far
to get one at one of the designated
sites
uh yes indeed mr speaker i i thank my
honourable friend for
uh for raising it i indeed i joined him
in thanking the nhs
staff who are scaling up testings the
search testing in the way that he
describes
and i encourage everybody in the area
and indeed throughout the country
to get a uh to get a vaccine when you're
asked to do so
let's come to the leader of the
opposition kirsten
mr speaker can i begin by thanking
everybody involved in the vaccine
rollout
we've now vaccinated i think 12.6
million people
and we're on course to vaccinate the
first four priority groups by the end of
this week
that's a truly amazing achievement
can the prime minister confirm today
that the government
will extend business rate relief beyond
march
31st
i'm afraid mr speaker i'm glad to hear
him uh joining praise of the
uh of the vaccine uh rollout which is in
indeed i think a tribute to
the nhs uh staff and uh the army
uh the volunteers and many many others
uh and uh on his uh point about
the uh extension of business rate
business rate relief uh he knows that
this government is committed to
supporting businesses and people
uh livelihoods uh throughout the
pandemic that is what we will continue
to do but he should wait
uh until the budget uh for the
chancellor uh to
uh explain exactly what we're gonna do
mr speaker i think that answer was that
the prime minister can't give an answer
yet but hundreds of thousands of
businesses are affected by this
and the trouble is mr speaker that
businesses don't work as slowly as the
prime minister
they need an answer now as the british
chamber of commerce says
businesses simply can't wait until the
march budget
let me try another vitally important
question for businesses
and for millions of working people can
the prime minister confirm today
that the furlough scheme will be
extended beyond april
mr speaker i think most people in this
country are aware that we're going
through a very serious
pandemic in which rates of infection
have been certainly brought down thanks
to the efforts of the rich people i
think also
members of this house are familiar uh
with the notion
that in just a few days we will be
setting out a road map for the way out
of this
uh pandemic a road map that i hope uh
the right honourable gentleman his
colleagues
will support they're the supporters we
know is tends to be a transitory thing
uh mr speaker one week we have it next
week uh we don't
but he won't have to contain himself for
very long
mr speaker let me let the prime minister
into a secret he can take decisions for
himself
and he doesn't need to leave everything
to the 11th minute if i will prevent
prime minister i'd say to
businesses we'll support you now we'll
protect jobs now
because the cbi the federation of small
businesses
the institute of directors and the
british chamber of commerce have all
said the same thing
they all say prime minister they can't
wait until the budget
the prime minister may disagree with me
but he's actually disagreeing with
businesses
why does the prime minister think he
knows better than british business
mr speaker i think that most uh business
people that i've talked i've talked to a
great many uh
in the last 12 months would agree that
there is no government around the world
that has done more
to support business wrapping our arms
around business and actually
i i'm delighted to hear this enthusiasm
uh for business from the
uh from the labour party uh when they
stood on a manifesto to destroy
uh capitalism at the last election and
indeed to dismantle the very
pharmaceutical industry
uh mr speaker that has provided uh the
vaccines
on which we now rely will he now
repudiate that policy mr speaker
mr speaker we all know what the prime
minister once said he wanted to do to
business
we on these benches would rather listen
to businesses
so so we've no decision on business
rates no decision on
furlough let's try another crucial issue
and prime minister no no excuse for
delaying this time because this has to
be decided before the march budget
and the prime minister doesn't need to
check with the chancellor so will the
prime minister
now commit to extending the evictions
ban on residential properties beyond
february the 21st
mr speaker i've said repeatedly that
what we will do
in this government and throughout this
pandemic is put our arms around the
british people support them
throughout the pandemic and make sure
that people are not unfairly
evicted during the pandemic that is what
we will we will do uh i what i hope very
much mr speaker we may hear from the
right honourable gentleman opposite that
he not only has now had a damascene
uh conversion to the importance of of
business
but a damascene conversion to supporting
all the government's policies
to support business rather than sniping
from the sidelines why is he just
get behind us and back the government
back us in our efforts to back business
and back the british people
yeah mr speaker i'm not going to take
lectures from a man who wrote two
versions of every column he ever wrote
as a journalist
who proposed donald trump for a nobel
peace prize
and gave dominic cummings a pay rise
back to the question
another area where the prime minister
repeatedly delayed
and now changes policy pretty well every
day is securing our
borders against variants of covid
every week the prime minister comes here
and says we've got one of the toughest
regimes in the world we know his home
secretary disagrees with him
we know the health secretary disagrees
with him luckily mr speaker oxford
university keep
track of how tough border restrictions
are in every country
they say that there are at least 33
countries around the world
which currently have tougher
restrictions for the united kingdom 33
prime minister
including canada denmark japan
israel there are many others in fact
they say we're not even in the top
bracket of countries for border
restrictions
50 days after we first discovered
discovered the south african variant
50 days how does the prime minister
explain that
mr speaker there is thank you mr speaker
there is there are
some countries in in europe that do not
even have a hotel quarantine
uh scheme such as the one we're putting
in on monday we have amongst the
toughest border regimes anywhere in the
world
but people should understand that on a
normal day mr speaker
at this time of year you could expect
about 250 000 people
uh to be arriving in this country we've
got it down to about 20 000
um 5 000 of them who are involved in
bringing vital things into this country
such as medicines and food as we
discussed
last week and he agreed that was a a
good idea mr speaker
uh unless he actually wants to cut this
country off
from the rest of the world which i think
last week he said he didn't want to do
unless of course he changed
his mind again mr speaker we have i
think that this
uh policy is measured it is
proportionate it is getting tougher
from monday i hope that he supports it
mr speaker the truth is this the prime
minister is failing to give security to
british businesses
and he's failing to secure our borders
the prime minister often complains that
we never put forward constructive
proposals
so here's two for him support businesses
and protect jobs now
by extending furlough business rate
relief and vat cuts for hospitality
and second secure our borders with a
comprehensive
hotel quarantine on arrival no more
delays
would he do it mr speaker we've just
announced
uh the uh the quarantine policy which as
i've said to the house
uh is amongst the the toughest in the in
the world
uh and and and tougher than most other
european countries
certainly i'm delighted that he's now
supporting business in his latest stunt
of bandwagoneering
uh a lot of not a policy for which he
was uh he was famous
uh before mr speaker uh but he you know
he moves from one side
of the other in the debate uh throughout
this crisis and
some people mr speaker on uh some people
have said that this is a good
crisis mr speaker some people have said
this is a good crisis
some people have said some people have
said that this crisis
is a gift that keeps on giving mr crisis
uh mr speaker uh this video those people
sit
on the labor front bench i think it is
disgraceful that they should say those
things i believe this is one of the
biggest challenges
this country has faced since the second
world war and thanks to one of the
fastest vaccine rollouts anywhere
in the world i believe it is a challenge
this country can meet
and is meeting and i believe that of
that vaccine rollout program
this house and this country should be
very
can i thank proud prime minister for the
decisions he took last year that have
meant that the vaccine
program is in such a good position at
this week
despite that success um it is vital that
that program
keeps pace with the changing variants
can he
update the house on where the uk stands
on ensuring that the uk supply chain is
in place
and that we don't get behind as the
virus mutates
prime minister my right honourable
friend asked an extremely important
question and that's why we recently
announced an agreement for 50 million
doses with the manufacturer curvac
because
we believe that that may help us to
develop
vaccines that can respond at scale uh to
new variants of the
of of the virus and as the house will
have heard uh
from uh from uh the chief medical
officer and the deputy chief medical
officer
and others uh we i think we're gonna
have to get used uh to
the idea of vaccinating and then
revaccinating
in the autumn as we as we come to face
uh these new variants
let's head up to sky and lockheed with
snp leader ian blatford
in blackfoot thank you mr speaker
new research from the joseph foundry
foundation and the baby bank charity
little village
has revealed that 1.3 million children
under 5 are living in poverty in the
united kingdom
this is a truly shocking figure that
should make this
tory government utterly ashamed the
scottish national party has repeatedly
called
for a financial package to boost
household incomes and reverse this tory
child poverty crisis the prime minister
has the power to tackle child poverty
right now
by making the 20 pound uplift to
universal credit permanent
and by extending it to legacy benefits
the tory government's been stalling on
this for months
will the prime minister finally act or
will he leave
millions of children out in the cold
minister mr speaker i think that the
uh whole house in this country should be
proud of the way we've tried to look
after people the poorest and neediest
families throughout
the country uh not just uh with uh
universal credit which
uh the party opposite would actually
abolish uh mr speaker but by helping
a vulnerable people with their food and
their uh their heating bills 170 million
pound
winter grant scheme looking after people
uh with the free school meal vouchers
and as i've said before mr speaker we
will put our arms around the people of
this entire country
throughout the pandemic let's return to
scotland with the in blackfood in
blackford
to say mr speaker that was pathetic that
was no answer
we're talking about 1.3 million children
under 5
in poverty let me quote she cried on her
doorstep because i gave her nappies
wipes and winter clothes for a child
i went away with a lump in my throat
these are the words of emily
a baby bank worker who's supporting
families that the tories have
pushed into poverty through a decade of
cuts they don't need more empty words
from a prime minister who simply
doesn't care enough to act mr speaker
this morning a new report from citizen
advice scotland
warned that tory cuts could reduce the
value of universal credit by as much
as a quarter just when people need this
money the most
well the prime minister agreed to meet
with me and other opposition parties
ahead of the budget for an urgent summit
on tackling child poverty
or will he be yet another tory prime
minister
who leaves a generation of children
languishing in poverty
mr speaker i must say that i i reject
entirely what the right honourable
dentist has just said because i don't
believe that any government could have
done more
to help the people of this country
throughout this pandemic and we will
continue
to do so and yes uh of course
uh we we bitterly we bitterly
uh lament and reject uh the poverty that
some families unquestionably suffer
and it is a and it is tragic that too
many families have had
a very very tough time during this
pandemic but we will continue
uh to support them in all the ways uh
that we have
uh we have set up and i may say to the
to the right honourable gentleman
there is a profound philosophical
difference between him and uh him and me
uh because the scottish nationalist
party is uh morphing into ever or a
left-wing
a party uh that believes that believes
fundamental there you go
there you go and mr speaker that
believes fundamentally that it is the
duty of the taxpayer uh to pay for more
and more and more
we want to get people into jobs mr
speaker and it's getting
and it's on that it's on that and it is
in that respect
that the scottish nationalist party is
unafraid of failing
there prime minister prime minister we
both know that you're only
teasing him and we're trying to wind up
the leader of the snp
please let's drop it let's move on
because lee
anderson is waiting for you lee
thank you mr speaker a new free port for
the east midlands will create over 60
000 new jobs
and provide a massive boost for
employers such as quantum engineering
and abacus in ashfield
after decades of neglect from labour mps
we now feel
a sense of hope in the red wall seas my
mum and dad voted conservative the first
time at the last general election
and were touched when the prime minister
acknowledged their votes were lent
could my right honourable friend the
prime minister please reassure my mum
and dad my friend
my family and all my constituents that
our area will never be let down again
prime minister absolutely mr speaker and
i thank my honorable friend for
everything he's doing for ashfield and
uh he and i have had enjoyable times
campaigning for the people of asheville
we'll continue
uh to do so and i can tell paul and
jenny uh that our commitment to leveling
up is absolutely rock solid
throughout this country they said to
murray on it with let's
saddle robert let's shovel roberts
who just heard the government claims to
have a leveling up agenda
underpinned by a research and
development roadmap
the trouble is the tories track record
on this
isn't good in fact it's abysmal wales
receives the lowest r
d spend per person of the four nations
at around
40 percent of spend per head in england
and westminster's obsession with the
golden triangle of
oxford cambridge and london shows no
sign of abating
will he now commit to a fairer devolved
r
d funding settlement to the senate or is
he content
for westminster's roadmap to be wales's
road to nowhere prime minister
mr speaker i'm afraid i think she's
doing a whales down and the people of
wales down
and the ingenuity of wales down because
i think
about a quarter of the airline
passengers in the world are born aloft
on
on wings made by the welsh aerospace
sector mr speaker
a bridge end uh is going to be one of
the great centers of battery
manufacturing
in this country if not the world wales
is at the cutting edge of technology
under this government's plans
for a record spending on uh on rmd 22
billion pounds by the end of this
parliament
wales along with the whole of the rest
of the uk will benefit massively
i said to cheshire with dr kieran mullen
dr kiera mullen
thank you mr speaker the uk has fallen
behind europe in untapping the potential
of geothermal heat and energy in places
like crew will the prime minister meet
with me to discuss how we can ensure
geothermal
helps us build back better with a
revitalized package of incentives for
industry
i i thank my honourable friend for the
excellent point he makes about crew
and the way it's now in the forefront of
uh of deep geothermal
uh energy uh exploration and uh very
happy to
to meet with him to discuss what we can
do to further geothermal energy
uh in crew diary permitting mr speaker
that's one dr bolton with jasmine
qureshi
yes me mr speaker
this government said that no council
would be suffering as a result of the
pandemic
and the chancellor said that he wouldn't
do everything
whatever it takes to help them yet the
tory controlled
bolton council has just announced 35
million
cuts in pounds and
increasing the council tax budget for
3.8
can the prime minister assure my
constituents and my town
that that money will be given to them or
will this join
a long list of tory failed promises
minister uh i want to congratulate mr
speaker the great conservative control
council of bolton
uh for everything they're doing and
continue to do throughout this pandemic
to look after the people
of bolton i i know uh what incredible
work local
officials do and i i thank them very
much for it and that and we believe that
since we believe so strongly in local
government
mr speaker as a creature of local
government uh myself
i'm proud that we've invested 4.6
billion pounds
uh in supporting local government uh
just so far in this pandemic
mr speaker from rainforest to coral
reefs the world's ecosystems are at risk
of catastrophic decline
that was the conclusion of the das gupta
review
last week which my right honourable
friend rightly welcomed
this threat to our biodiversity is not
just a moral failure it is economically
short-sighted too
when i asked professor dasgupta to carry
out this work
he told me that it would not be complete
until after the uk had hosted the cop26
summit
but now given that the summit has been
delayed until later this year
and that will take place alongside our
presidency
of the g7 does my right honourable
friend agree with me
that the uk has been presented with a
unique
opportunity to show global leadership on
how we can better protect our most
precious asset
nature my right honourable friend is
absolutely right i thank him for what
he's doing himself in the in this area
and i
i want uh the house to know that we we
want
uh our cops the u.n cop 26 summit uh
to be a landmark event not just for
tackling climate change but also in
in biodiversity and i think it's high
time that the leaders
of the world took a step to reverse
the loss of habitats and species that
we've seen over the last century
let's head up to oxfordshire with leila
moran layla morale
thank you mr speaker it's estimated that
up to 400
000 people are living with the
debilitating effects of long covert and
some of these are nhs
heroes who caught covert in that first
wave
nearly a year later i've heard from a
doctor who says
she wonders if she'll ever be able to
walk unaided again let alone manage
a full day of work does the prime
minister recognize that for this group
long covert is an occupational disease
and will he set up
a compensation scheme similar to what we
offer our armed forces
so that we ensure that those who have
lost their livelihoods by saving lives
are fully supported
thank the the honorable lady because
she's right to
highlight the incredible sacrifice and
effort of
nhs staff many of whom uh sadly
have contracted covert in the course of
their of their duties
and uh a great many of whom uh
have sadly continued to be affected by
that disease we must study the long-term
uh effects of kovid and make sure that
we continue
to look after our wonderful nhs staff
throughout their careers
senator yorkshire with julian standing
julian stanley
thank you mr speaker can the prime
minister confirm today that all students
will be back in school no later
than the 8th of march and commit to
starting
any phased return straight after half
term
so that the really damaging effects of
being away from school
are known are not drawn out for any
longer than is absolutely necessary
mr speak i can certainly confirm that
we're going to do everything we can and
i know that that's the
uh the settled uh will of most people in
this
uh in this house to get uh our ours our
kids get uh school children
back uh on march the eighth if we
possibly can
i'll be setting out for my honorable
friend uh as much as we can say
in uh on monday and then uh in the in
the week of the 22nd
uh we'll be setting out a road map uh
and
uh and sending out the way forward for
schools but uh we've got to make sure we
keep this virus under control mr speaker
it is coming down
uh but we we cannot take our foot uh off
the
uh off its throat let's head up to the
northeast with ian manns immense
very grateful mr speaker having sat on
the hs2 hybrid bill committee for 15
months i was a skeptic as to the
economic benefits of the project for the
northeast
buddha chest 2 is going ahead at least
in the south
it's therefore crucial that the eastern
leg of hs2 goes ahead
not just for yorkshire in the east
midlands but also for the northeast
the prime minister has made repeated
promises to the people of the northeast
of his intention to level up
and to connect and create opportunities
for people here in places like gateshead
so
as we strive to recover from the damage
done to so many
families and businesses by the pandemic
will the prime minister commit the
beginning the work on the eastern leg of
vhs2
starting in the northeast to run
simultaneously with the construction in
the south
so that our region is not forced to wait
another couple of decades for 21st
century rail connectivity
mr speaker i can certainly confirm that
we are going to develop the
uh eastern leg as well as the whole of
hs2 and
uh he'll be hearing a lot more about uh
what we're going to do with our
uh our national infrastructure
revolution uh mr speaker
uh and uh about what we're gonna do uh
to uh improve uh
not just rail transport but road
transport
as well in the northeast let's head
south to caroline nancy lewis audio
carolina thank you mr speaker
there is no shortage of commitment or
compassion
in my town of eastbourne for homeless
people who are vulnerable and need
complex
support however neighbouring brighton
continues to send its homeless to our
town
and we do not have the resources to meet
this need
three homeless people have died and i
believe there will be inquests
brighton is not engaging with
eastbourne's council in any meaningful
way and a further 51
placements have been made in recent
weeks
will my right honourable friend join
with me in urging
immediate engagement from brighton hope
council leaders
on this as a matter of urgency
yes indeed mr speaker uh and i thank uh
brighton council and uh and easter for
cooperating
uh with uh uh with eastbourne uh council
in getting this done there must be uh
cooperation
uh no one in this country should be
living rough or sleeping or a homeless
as a sleeping ruffle or being all
homeless as a result of this pandemic or
d
through any other cause mr speaker we've
invested 700 million
this year to help people off the streets
uh it continues to be
a national uh priority and i'm grateful
to my right honourable friend
the secretary of state for communities
and local government of what he's doing
and the various task forces that are
currently work to prevent uh people
coming out
on the streets again as we as we lift
the restrictions
let's center south wales with garant
davis garant
mr speaker at dvla in swansea
there had been 526 cases of coronavirus
since last september when the prime
minister told us
the prime minister's question time all
staff who can work from home
are working from home yet in march last
year 250 people were working on site
now the numbers are in their thousands
facing a more infectious and widespread
disease
and yesterday 90 people were sent home
following the latest
outbreak of coronavirus just before the
weekend
so given that bt are on standby to
install
home secure technology to allow home
working
will the prime minister meet with me and
the
union pcs ahead of the strike ballot
next week so that workplace numbers can
be reduced until the vaccine is rolled
out
to keep people safe and to avoid an
unnecessary strike
mr speaker i i thank him for for raising
this again
uh with me and uh thanks to the uh the
working from home strategy that the dvla
has been pursuing
of a workforce of six thousand there are
currently only thankfully there are only
uh nine cases to the best of my
knowledge uh of
uh of covid uh and three of those
individuals
are currently working from home we're
we're rolling out lateral flow tests
a huge number of lateral flow tests uh
are being distributed to the
to the dvla but the the long-term
solution
uh mr speaker or the medium-term
solution i should say is to is to
vaccinate
and to roll out the vaccination program
and that is what this government
is doing in wales and across the country
i said to the west midlands with little
richards network
thank you mr speaker families across
west bromwich have been affected by
cancer just like my own
and know all too well that early
diagnosis and treatment can save a life
according to research by macmillan
cancer support there were over 70 people
in my constituency
and 50 000 across the uk with a missing
cancer diagnosis
cancer hasn't stopped during the
pandemic so with this in mind will the
prime minister commit to making
the resurgence of cancer diagnosis
services a top priority as restrictions
begin to ease
minister i i thank my my honorable
friend and i know this is an issue that
is
uh that is very close to uh to her heart
and she's right
uh to raise it because we of course are
the pressures from
kovid but we're also worried mr speaker
that some people
may not be coming forward for the cancer
treatments
uh that they need so i urge everybody uh
who who needs to get their treatment uh
to help uh the nhs
to help you uh come forward and and get
your treatment as you normally would
let's head to the northwest with lucy
powell lucy
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
said in november
that the 1.5 billion pound green homes
grant would be extended
to march 2022 yet in a written answer
last week his minister said that the
money would not
be carried over from this financial year
to next
with just seven weeks to go a poultry
71 million pounds has been spent so far
so why is he cutting one billion pounds
from the green homes grant that he
promised for businesses
homeowners and the environment
she's she's she's on to something but
she's barking up the wrong tree mr
speaker
uh the the the the the problem uh with
the green homes
uh grant uh is is is not that we're not
cutting it the problem is there hasn't
been enough
take-up and we want us we want to
encourage people uh to take it up and
make use
of the opportunity uh to reduce the
carbon emission
of your homes i said so roger gail sir
roger
the prime minister said and he's written
in his forward to the environment white
paper
that he's pledged to protect the
countryside
mr speaker the countryside is more than
just a bit of green belt around the home
counties
in westgate and birchington and hearne
bay in my own constituency
and indeed across much of the garden of
england there are plans to smother acres
of prime agricultural land in housing
that is not needed for local people but
that is needed and required to grow the
crops to reduce
the amount of food that we import at a
cost of carbon emissions
so if the prime minister is the friend
of the countryside
will he announce an immediate moratorium
on the use of all farmland for housing
while the whole policy is reviewed
mr speaker i i i think i just heard the
honourable gentleman say that he wants
an
immediate moratorium on the construction
of of all
of all housing uh but maybe i i miss
i misunderstood i don't think that to be
uh realistic but what i can certainly
tell him
is that uh we will take very seriously
points he makes i know that my rightful
friend
uh the secretary of state for
communities and local government uh has
met him and we'll be glad to
meet him again to discuss the the
subject he raises
but this government's commitment to
nature and to the countryside
is unmatched we've just consecrated 30
percent
of our land surface mr speaker to nature
let's head up to andre with
neil gray hilgrey thank you mr speaker
i had a meeting recently with the pcs
about public sector pay and heard from
constituents and shots and calder bank
who work for uk
government departments both are
struggling to cover
over a real terms pay cut over decades
one has had to take partial early
retirement so the lump sum could keep
him going
what will the prime minister say to the
chancellor to convince him of the need
to properly reward
all those who have been on the front
line during the covert pandemic
and at the very least follow the
scottish government's lead
in fully funding a rise in public sector
pay prime minister
mr speaker uh we have seen above
inflation increases in uh in public
sector pay and that is and that is quite
right
and we support uh we support uh
particularly
increases in uh investment in our in our
nhs until know the package that we put
in place
for nurses but the single best thing
that we can do is support
the living wage which this government
introduced and which we have now which
this government introduced and which we
have now uh increased
by record amounts two years uh in a row
and i see the scottish nationalist party
forgive me uh this is bigger national
i'm not i don't know whether the
nationalist or perhaps they could clear
it up whether they think
whether
are there national party without being
nationalists isn't it interesting
semantic point mr speaker uh but uh they
i think they're trying to claim that
they pioneered the uh the living wage i
don't think that's right mr speaker i
i seem to remember that it was a certain
um mayoralty in london
uh that massively increased the living
wage when they weren't off the starting
blocks mr speaker
in which case let's go down to somerset
who is ready on the starting blocks with
ian little granger
mr speaker thank you as always i am
delighted my vulnerable friend is
defending democracy by pushing ahead
with local elections but here in the
land of king alfred
the people desperately want to give
their verdict on somerset county council
which i'm afraid has been using coded
money to spend on things that have
nothing to do with the pandemic
they have submitted to the government a
form which
says that nothing and i fear that my
right on befriend has been misled
we need a referendum down here to test
public opinion
quickly but would my right honourable
friend a proud man of somerset
who understands history more than most
of us not agree the time has come to put
our county back together
and that we have the whole of somerset
being looked after by somerset
i know king alfred approve of it and i
know the people of somerset will
certainly support the prime minister
if he supports us prime minister
mr speaker i i i thank my
run friend who is a great advocate of
somerset and committed to his
uh constituents uh and i i thank him for
what he
he's doing uh he's he's raised this now
twice with with me
uh i thank you for that but uh my my
humbly suggests that
the best way forward is for the
consultation to uh proceed and for
uh local people to decide uh what the
best form
of government local government uh the is
that they
uh that they want let's head for our
final question from northern ireland
with gregory campbell
gregory campbell thank you mr speaker
prime minister
you're aware of the problems we warned
about over many months
before the northern ireland protocol was
introduced
these problems are scheduled to get
worse for april
can you outline a timeline where people
in northern ireland
and indeed all across the uk as
indicated
in the parliament petition last week
when all of us can enjoy free trade
across the nation including from gb to
ni
as every other independent trading
nation enjoys
yes indeed mr speaker and uh i've made
it absolutely
clear to our uh uh eu friends and and
partners
that uh we want to make uh our
relationship work
but it is also absolutely essential uh
that uh there should be untrammeled free
trade exchange of goods people services
and capital
uh through all parts of the uk
and uh we will do everything we can to
ensure that that is the case including
uh as i've as i've said in the chamber
before and
uh to his honorable colleagues including
vocal invoking article 16 of the
protocol if that is necessary
i'm suspending the house for three
minutes to enable the necessary
arrangements for the next business to be
made
well one thing that uh prime minister's
questions will be remembered for is
boris johnson even for him exceptionally
tousled hair
uh what else uh with me is our
definitely political editor sam codes
i think uh there was just one
announcement from boris johnson that i
think will
reverberate it's a confirmation of what
we had been hearing from others but he
said we are going to have to get used to
the idea of vaccinating people
and then re-vaccinating them in the
autumn
as we face new variants so the vaccine
program people had been expecting two
jabs now it looks like in order to deal
with these new mutations
that's going to keep going you have just
today the new bristol variant which
combines the speed of transmission
of the kent variant with some of the
vaccine resistant properties of the
south african variant
there could be there is some concern in
government about that
here is how they'll tackle it a couple
of other significant things from uh
prime minister's questions
kirstama looked at trying to press the
prime minister
about what will happen to business rate
now there's a moratorium for some
businesses on paying that which comes to
an end this month
uh on furlough which comes to an end uh
in at the end of may
and commercial eviction moratorium which
uh comes to an end uh
later this month and he pressed the
prime minister are we going to say
extensions to all of those now
to my ear it sounded like boris johnson
was hinting yes but not yet there's a
budget on march the third
he suggested that he might even announce
some of
the plans around those schemes before
then when he lays out his roadmap on
in the week beginning february the 22nd
but
as as far as lifting deadlines bringing
in
or extending financial support and
indeed reopening schools i got the
impression that there are no deadlines
things are slipping a bit
so there was a question from the
consecutive mp julian
sturdy which quite frankly we're all
puzzling the answer over now he asked
for an assurance that all pupils would
be back on school uh from march the 8th
and what boris johnson said was that
he'll do all he can to make this happen
into the settlement of the commons to do
that
he said the government will say more
about this on monday next week
and then more about that again in the
roadmap coming the week starting
february the
22nd now two things strike you about
that first of all we weren't expecting a
statement
on schools uh a week uh well next monday
so
uh why is he doing that is that uh to
change the timetable or
uh to delay the timetable for re-opening
in some way and secondly as you say
sounds a bit as if that timetable's
slipping because we had expected the
statement on the roadmap to be
on february the 22nd now it's just the
week beginning february 22nd
and ian blackford already on social
media
attacking the prime minister for not
answering his question about the latest
statistics of children in poverty
uh why did the prime minister brush that
off so the prime minister was pretty
hard-hitting response to that
he said look our your priority is
raising welfare spending our
priority is to get um people back in
jobs there is a strand of conservative
thinking
that doesn't particularly like the child
poverty targets as defined by the labour
party
they think that they're not particularly
well directed and they think there are
other solutions to questions
like that but the prime minister's
answer sounded um
particularly sort of brutal in some ways
to in blackford's question
you might want to help child poverty we
will um uh support uh
jobs it was a um prime minister's
questions where everyone was rolling out
their uh
rhetorical gags their rhetorical punch
and gd uh jibes
uh kistama had a line uh against boris
johnson about
uh how boris johnson was the leader with
two versions of every column when he was
a journalist
wanted donald trump for the nobel peace
prize dominic cummings to get a pay rise
uh boris johnson had his pre-prepared
line for uh kirstama
uh where he pointed to the mp on the
labour benches uh who called coronavirus
a good crisis that's a reference to
kate green he later had to apologize and
coronavirus being a gift that keeps on
giving
that's a reference to weekend stories
about lord faulkner now
the lord thought the story is actually a
bit more complicated about that he was
talking about lawyers interested in law
changes um but
uh there were boom tisch moments in
prime minister's questions i'm not sure
i'd already been pointed out that um
guess who mr johnson actually said
something similar
uh that the the coronavirus did open up
opportunities in
his uh conference speech boris johnson
said we have massive opportunities now
to you to use this unquestionable crisis
i mean it's a bit of a huge thing for
our country to build back better
he would say he's referring to things
like the wholesale reform of things like
public health england which
is shortly to disappear a body that's
much criticizing is handling the
pandemic
but you know parallels will be drawn
with what um uh with what labour figures
have been saying today the thing did
strike me was
conservative mps with their questions
really no more supportive than the
opposition mps overall
when you look at people like roger gale
who's turned into quite a trenchant
critic of the government talking about
environmental housing policy
uh through to several others you know
even the question about schools wasn't
exactly
friendly it's um i think you're right
let's go to the community secretary
robert generic who's making a statement
about
cladding on buildings uh following the
grenfell tower disaster the foundations
of these ambitions and the mission of my
department
our safety and fairness
we've all been moved by the stories
we've heard
and the people that we've met homeowners
placed
in difficult sometimes impossible
situations through no fault of their own
i appreciate the frustration the worry
and at times the despair that they feel
i share their anger at the errors the
omissions the false promises
and even the outright dishonesty that
came
before us built up over many decades
but which this government is determined
to tackle that's why mr speaker today
i'm announcing an unprecedented
intervention
a clear plan to remove unsafe cladding
to provide certainty to leaseholders to
make the industry pay for its
faults of the past to create a
world-class
building safety regime and to inject
confidence
and certainty back into this part of the
housing market
firstly we will finish the job that
we've started
on remediating unsafe cladding
after the tragedy of grenfell tower the
expert advice that
this government received identified
aluminium composite cladding
acm the material on the tower
as by far the most unsafe form of
cladding
it should never have been used and our
independent expert advisory panel
recommended that this should be the
focus of our remediation
work thanks to a very considerable
effort
including during the pandemic almost 95
of all high-rise buildings identified by
the beginning of last year with unsafe
acm cladding have now been remediated or
workers are on site now doing the job
and that rises to 100 percent in social
housing
and guided again by expert advice the
work to remove
other types of cladding which are also
unsafe albeit
less so than acm where it poses a
genuine risk to life
is also underway
it was always our expectation
our demand that building owners and
developers should step up
to meet the cost of this work where they
haven't
or where they no longer exist the
government has stepped in
providing 1.6 billion pounds to
remediate
unsafe cladding however
it's clear that without further
government intervention
many building owners will simply seek to
pass these potentially very significant
costs
onto leaseholders as this is often
the legal position in the leases that
they signed
that would risk punishing those who've
worked hard
who've bought their own home but through
no fault
of their own have found themselves
caught
in an absolutely invidious situation
importantly it also risks slowing down
the critical works
to make these homes safer
i am therefore today making an
exceptional intervention on behalf of
the government
and providing certainty that
leaseholders in high-rise residential
buildings
will face no cost for cladding
remediation
works we will make further funding
available to pay for the removal and
replacement
of unsafe cladding for all leaseholders
in high-rise
residential buildings of 18 meters
and above or above six storeys in
england
we continue to take a safety led
approach
and this funding will focus on the
higher rise buildings
where the independent expert advisory
panel tells us
time and again the overwhelming majority
of the safety
risk lies in line with the existing
building safety fund
and the anticipated scope of the new
building safety regulator
that we're establishing and will shortly
be legislating for
this will ensure that we end the
cladding scandal in a way that is fair
and generous to leaseholders
secondly for lower and medium rise
blocks of flats the risks are
significantly
lower and the remediation of cladding is
less likely to be needed in many cases
it will not be needed at all but where
it is
costs can still be significant for
leaseholders
which is why i'm announcing today the
government will develop a long-term
scheme
to protect leaseholders in this
situation
with financial support for cladding
remediation on buildings between
four and six stories under a long-term
low interest scheme no leaseholder
will ever pay more than 50 pounds a
month
towards the removal of unsafe cladding
many far less taken together
this means the government is providing
more than 5 billion pounds including a
further
3.5 billion pounds announced today plus
the significant cost of the very
generous financing scheme
which will run for many years to come to
ensure
all leaseholders in medium and high rise
blocks face no costs or very
low costs if cladding remediation is
needed
where it is costs can still be
significant
for leaseholders which
is why we want to take these important
steps we want to ensure
that the government develops this
long-term scheme which will protect
leaseholders with financial support
taken together this means that the
government
helps leaseholders to move forwards with
greater certainty
and more confidence about the future
thirdly whilst the problem is not one of
leaseholders
making it is also the case
that it cannot be right that the costs
of addressing these issues fall solely
on taxpayers
many of whom are not themselves
homeowners
and can only dream of getting on the
housing ladder
the government has always expected the
industry to contribute
towards these costs and some have done
so
today i'm announcing that we will
introduce a gateway to developer
levy that will be implemented through
the forthcoming
building safety bill the proposed levy
will be targeted and only apply when
developers seek permission
to develop certain high-rise buildings
in england
helping to ensure the industry take
collective responsibility
for historic building safety defects
in introducing the levy we will continue
to ensure
the homes our country needs get built
and that our small and medium-sized
builders are protected
in addition a new tax will be introduced
for the uk residential property
development sector
in 2022 this will raise at least two
billion
pounds over a decade to help pay for
cladding remediation
costs the tax will ensure the largest
property developers make a fair
contribution to the remediation program
in relation to the money they make from
residential
property reflecting the benefit that
they will derive
from restoring confidence to the uk
housing market the government will
consult
on the policy design in due course
fourthly i know there are many people
across the country who are concerned
about the safety
of their home in the actions we've taken
and those that we take today we've
already prioritized
very clearly public safety however it's
also
important that we put the risk of a fire
and in particular the risk of a fatal
fire
into context it is low
last year the number of people who died
in fires in blocks of flats
over 11 meters was 10
an all-time low and fire related
fatalities
in dwellings in england have fallen by
29
over the last decade by way of
comparison
over 1700 fatalities were reported
on our roads in 2019
now of course any death is one too many
and the tragedy of grenfell tower
lingers with us and demands action
that's why it's right that we address
safety issues where they exist and are a
threat
to life but do so in a proportionate
way and guided at all times by expert
advice that is the approach we're taking
through the building safety bill the new
building safety regulator the fire
safety
bill and the new national regulator of
construction products
that i announced in january i'm
determined
that we have a world-class building
safety
regime but lastly
we need everyone to follow this sensible
proportionate approach so that this part
of the housing market
can now move forwards and homeowners are
not disproportionately
impacted the royal institute of
chartered surveyors have consulted on
new guidance
for valuers on when an ews one form
should actually be required the
government endorses
its work to ensure that assessors have a
stronger basis
on which to make good proportionate
judgments
about valuation risk lenders have
welcomed the progress
on this guidance which will help ensure
that over half
a million leaseholders in blocks of
flats over 11 meters
will not need a separate ews one
assessment
to get a mortgage this builds on the
interventions that we've already made
to create and train many more assessors
and we're doing so further so that they
can access professional indemnity
insurance
to get on with the job so today
in addition to providing certainty to
leaseholders
we're also providing confidence to
lenders
and following discussions my writable
friend the chancellor and i have had
with the lenders we expect all of the
major banks and building societies
to strongly support today's intervention
which will provide greater certainty to
the market
and help to restore the effective
lending purchasing
and selling of properties as soon as
possible
taken together mr speaker this
exceptional intervention
amounts to the largest ever government
investment
in building safety we believe in home
ownership
and today we firmly support the hundreds
of
thousands of homeowners who need our
help
now i commend this statement to the
house
i will call thanks participating
virtually
who was six minutes in which to respond
thank them debonair
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
secretary of state for advanced site of
his statement
buying your first home should be a dream
come true
but for many it's now been a nightmare
for years
as a result of government choices three
and a half years on from the grand fall
tragedy in which 72 people lost their
lives
hundreds of thousands of people are
still trapped in unsafe homes
many more unable to move and today's
announcement is too late
for too many it's a repeat of
undelivered promises
and backtracks on the key one that
leaseholders should have no
costs to pay the chancellor said last
march
all unsafe combustible cladding will be
removed from every private and social
residential building above 80 metres
high
but that has not happened buildings
haven't been able to access the fund
and nine pounds out of ten is still
sitting where it was
at every stage the government
underestimated the problem
and delays caused it to grow they still
don't know how many buildings are unsafe
where they are or what danger they pose
until we have answers to those basic
questions government will continue to
make mistakes
offering piecemeal solutions that then
have to be updated when they don't
deliver
so i ask can the minister can the
secretary of state guarantee the funding
will cover
cover all buildings over 18 meters
what will the consequential be for the
devolved administrations
including wales we can't have a repeat
of the first come first serve
free-for-all
where the most dangerous blocks risk
being fixed last so will the government
set up an independent task force as
labour is asked for
to prioritize buildings according to
risk have powers to get the funds out of
the door and to be able to go after the
building owners who fail to get on with
the work
government ministers have now promised
17 times
that leaseholders will not bear the cost
of fixing a problem they didn't cause
many will be listening to the housing
secretary's remarks today
and the government has betrayed their
promise that leaseholders wouldn't pay
for the building safety crisis
as i said three and a half years on from
grenfell hundreds of thousands
hundreds of thousands can't sleep at
night because their homes are unsafe
the government has chosen today to pile
financial misery on them
this is an injustice what does the
housing secretary say to julie in
runcorn
who lives in a flat with dangerous hpl
cladding her block is under 18 meters
so she's unable to access funding
promise so far she lives in the same
development as buildings with the exact
same cladding
but over 80 meters so they will be able
to access the fund
why should this arbitrary 18 meter
height limit mean the difference between
a safe home and financial ruin
what are the terms of the loans what
will the interest rate be and will
leaseholders be required to pay the
interest as well as the main cost
and he says these holders won't pay more
than 50 pounds a month
does that stay with the current owners
when they move or with the home if the
new owner is forced to pay
how long does it run for will it go up
by inflation each year
and what will government do if those
homes remain unsellable
how will they ensure that freeholders
take up the loans how will government
speed up remediation because the current
stalemate cannot continue
and then there are others who don't have
dangerous planning but have been charged
hundreds of thousands of pounds up to
sorry
thousands of pounds per flat to fix
other fire safety issues
what does the housing secretary say to
them the government should focus on
securing our economy and rebuilding from
covid
not saddling homeowners with further
debt when they have further debt
that means less money for our economic
recovery taking money away from local
shops
it reinforces regional imbalances and it
makes young first-time buyers and
pensioners pay money they can't afford
the government should pursue those
responsible fully to present prevent
leaseholders and taxpayers from carrying
the can
the government has announced the levy
and attacks which i welcome because
those responsible should bear the cost
but how much
does the government anticipate this levy
will raise and will the government
pursue others such as cladding
manufacturers also responsible for
putting the dangerous cladding
government has missed every target for
removing acm cladding and there are
still 50
000 people living in flats wrapped in it
the same cladding is found on grenfell
tower thousands more with other
dangerous cladding
so will the minister commit today to
remove all dangerous cladding by 2022.
as the secretary of state will know at
least one first-time home owner
haley has already been made bankrupt
before she was even asked to pay for
remediation
just from the extra costs she asked
government to think about her former
neighbors
when will leaseholders start receiving
funding to pay for the round-the-clock
fire patrols they've been charged
hundreds of pounds each month for
what about the skyrocketing insurance
and how will government get the market
moving and their last announcement fell
to pieces the housing market in affected
homes is grinding to a halt
and a simple question what on average
does he expect the leaseholder to be
paying
mr speaker finally government in action
and delay has caused the building safety
crisis to spiral
people cannot continue to live in unsafe
unsellable homes
they shouldn't face homeowners shouldn't
they